so
[Music]
do
hello
how are you guys doing this evening
yes very good nice nice to see each one
of you guys
so welcome to the table uh my name is
dawn jacobs i'm just one of the
leadership people
that's here would love to also welcome
those of you who are joining us online
i love that you are tuning in and
participating with us in that way as
well um so i just only have
you know two quick announcements uh so
tonight we are doing our welcome to the
table class uh basically what that means
if you are interested in joining the
church and you want to officially join
you want to you can attend this class
we'll tell you all the details and that
comes along with what that means you
hear us hosted by brett you'll hear all
the different things about you know you
know our church and all the different
things that you know just make the
church the church
if you are just even just interested and
you're you're still just kind of curious
not one percent sure if you want to
officially join you're still welcome to
come
if you didn't sign up for it
that's okay
come anyway
so we'd still still you are welcome to
be here we will just be just after the
service uh tonight
and then just one other quick
announcement is that we are having a um
ash wednesday
service
so it's going to be march the 2nd and
we're actually doing that with pleasant
valley so it's going to be here
so it's going to be a joint
uh service so it's always kind of
exciting when we do joint things with
pleasant valley um so that's going to be
seven o'clock 7 p.m this will be kind of
short it's about 30 minutes so it won't
be an entire hour long service and then
some uh so but we would encourage you to
come participate if that's something
you're interested
other than that um
we'll get started right before worship i
will say i do love coming in here first
thing and just having a couple of
moments i get to see like a sneak peek
of what they've got planned
and it's just really interesting to kind
of see them kind of put everything
together so i get really excited to kind
of see some of the songs you guys are at
your own risk
[Laughter]
so anyways so let's uh let's pray
lord thank you so much
for just bringing us here
thank you for this space
thank you for this time
thank you for just
the ability to
be able to sit at your feet
learn more about your son and who we are
in relationship to you
i pray that you open our hearts our
minds
to
this moment
just help us to forget about
things that might be wearing us down
and just help just kind of release some
of that stuff
um because we know that you're going to
give us peace we know that you can give
us comfort
um and i pray that for those of us who
are just needing that we can find that
here
in christ center pray amen
amen
thank you don all right if you guys want
to stand up with us you are more than
welcome to
this is an open space this is open
worship so it's for all of us it's not
um
something for us to perform for you it's
something for us to engage in as a
community and for me it's one of those
moments where i get to engage a little
bit of the creativity and the beauty
that i find in music and meet god there
so maybe it's in the lyrics maybe it's
in the music itself um or maybe it's
just having this communal moment where
i'm hearing your voices and you're
hearing our voices and there's not a lot
of like communal singing anymore right
like unless you're at a concert maybe
and everybody like comes in in a chorus
and it's like that powerful moment
because it doesn't happen very often
anymore you know so this is our moment
during the week to
be able to lift up voices together and
hopefully sing words that are going to
resonate with you truth that is going to
carry you maybe through a dark time or
just in this space where you can feel
um seen or understood or maybe just
experiencing something new of god so
welcome to the space with us please join
in as you want to all right
amen
[Music]
let's all sing that together one more
time lift it up
[Music]
it feels
is
[Music]
there is freedom
i am
[Music]
is
of is lord is
[Music]
free
at last
[Music]
i am
is
[Music]
there is freedom
i
am
[Music]
is
lovely
[Music]
you are here
moving in our
midst
i worship you
you are here
working in this place
[Music]
you are here
working in this
[Music]
keep
that is
[Music]
in the darkness my god that is
you are here
[Music]
healing every heart
you are here
[Music]
keep the night in the darkness my god
that is who you are
[Music]
that is who you
my are
that is
[Music]
my god that is who you are
is who you are
[Music]
you never stop
never
[Music]
you never
you'll never
[Music]
my god
is
[Music]
we make a miracle worker promise keeper
light in the darkness my god
that is who you are
waymaker miracle worker promise keeper
light in the darkness
my god that is who you are
that is who you are
[Music]
keeper light in the darkness my god that
is are
[Music]
we want to remember those
we need that hope god
as we move into the prayers of the
people i just encourage you if there's
something that's weighing on your heart
someone or a situation that you're
carrying
tonight feel free to lift them up and
let us shoulder that with you let us as
we speak out those names
and those situations let us carry those
with you and believe that god is also
with us
carrying our burdens
would you guys read this with me
for the city of saxi texas and for every
city and community and all of those who
live in them
we pray to you for the good earth that
you have given us and the wisdom and the
will to conserve it
we pray to you
for those who travel on land sea or air
we pray to you for the old and the sick
for the widow and the orphan
for the injured and the suffering
we pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and destitute
for prisoners and captives and for all
who remember and care for them
we pray to you
lord we know that you love us
and that you hear us
and so now we lift these names and
situations
for the
ramses
from online prayers for our teachers and
educators
and i think thankful that james mom's
surgery went well
for these names and moments that we have
spoken aloud and for those that we have
kept in our hearts
we pray to you that they may have life
and light
healing and hope
peace
and a deep sense of your presence
amen
i'm just going to say something real
quick
you can probably tell i'm having a hard
time keeping it together up here it's a
really vulnerable spot to be standing
and not being able to get it together
we have a few friends in our lives that
are really struggling this last week
with
some pretty serious mental health and
just singing songs about
god being light in our darkness
and god being a place where we're free
it's
really got to mean so
i just felt like i should say something
this is on my heart and i'm up here
really vulnerably watching everybody's
watching me cry
i'm gonna try to
drive up here
not sniff my way through this
[Music]
give me vision
to see things like you do
god i look to you
you're where my help comes from
give me wisdom
[Music]
you know just what to do
give me vision
to see things like you do
god i look to you
you're where my help comes from
give me wisdom
you know just what to do
[Music]
and i will love you
lord my strength
[Music]
and i will love you
lord my
rock
forever all my days i will love you god
and i will love you
lord my strength
[Music]
forever all my days
you guys
hallelujah
[Music]
and hallelujah
hallelujah
[Music]
[Laughter]
and i will love you lord my
shield
and i will love you lord my rock
forever all my days
you guys
[Music]
god thank you that you care about the
things that we care about
that you know the burdens that we walk
in here with
you know the struggles and the pain
you know our past
you know our traumas
you know our addictions
and yet you show up here and you meet us
in your kindness
and in your love
and you fill us with strength
and you say that we're beautiful
and you are enough for us
your grace
is enough for us
your life
god where we struggle to fill the void
with so many other things would your
life and your light penetrate every dark
place in our lives
every hopeless spot in our hearts god
would your light come through
jesus we just acknowledge the need
for hope
we acknowledge the need for life
for truth
for help
so we keep looking to you we keep
turning our eyes towards you
we placing our trust in you
your goodness
that love source
that never runs dry that never turns us
away
that never sees us as too far gone
would we not only find that a new god
but would we also offer that to each
other
that hope
that promise
of resurrection and redemption
and new life
would you do a new thing in us
would you heal the broken places
and would we walk beside one another god
as we heal
would we be the shoulder
the friend
the support the ear
this community is a gift god
would we remember that
we love you we thank you for this time
together god continue to speak to our
hearts
continue to be with us
it's in your name i pray
jesus amen
thank you guys so much for worshiping
together if you guys want to sit and
turn to the people around you say hello
and welcome them as brett comes to give
us our message
all right
good evening
grace and peace y'all
you doing okay
that was a beautiful beautiful time of
worship really meaningful um so thank
you team for leading us and um
thank god for his faithfulness and
goodness to um just meet us over and
over and over
week after week in this place it's a
it's really really beautiful
um
so
we are well let me first before i forget
i want to greet of course all of you but
uh especially those joining us online
love y'all lots you are not forgotten
and so glad we could worship with you
and connect with you in this way
and um also anyone who is new here or
maybe just kind of making their way into
the community
i know depending on church background
you know something there can
there can be uh sometimes there can be
baggage you know coming into a church
space um
in fact even sometimes even just the the
architecture and like the feel you know
being back in a in like literally a
church building you know like even that
can be really challenging for folks
sometimes um and uh or even if you don't
have that baggage maybe you're just kind
of plugging in and um it still can just
be a little bit scary you know so um
thank you for having the courage to to
be here
so we are um
we're just going through the book of
peter so our series right now is first
peter part two
and uh we will
um see next week will be our kind of
last message in at least part two of
this series and we'll kind of hit the
pause button again because we're gonna
be going into uh the season of lent uh
the uh in that first um sunday in march
so
um at any rate but for now we're still
working through
first peter
um so the title of my message tonight is
uh five signs of a true church so if
you're a note taker you can jot that
down five signs of a true church and our
primary text tonight is actually going
to be just one
verse
nice and simple i promise
no roman history tonight
[Laughter]
don't get too excited over there mindy
don't be too like too excited
maybe there's probably like three of you
who are like oh man but
then for the rest of you you're like oh
actually it will be a pretty um i would
call this a uh
pretty light you know so it's a light
message um
but i hope still um meaningful you know
um
so see our text is first peter three
verse eight so he writes these words um
he says finally now by this he just
means to sum up everything i've been
saying last few chapters he doesn't mean
it i don't think like sarcastically
finally um you know it's just a sense of
in summation
uh all of you
speaking to the church be like-minded
be sympathetic love one another be
compassionate and humble
so there you have the message right
there those are the five signs of uh of
a true church so what i want to do is
just walk through each of these words
and just kind of unpack them and really
reflect on um like what does this mean
for us what does this mean for like our
lives like individually and us as a
church community you know what is this
um kind of calling us to in a sense so
um so this first one is uh like-minded
other interpretations here of this greek
word could be just a sense of harmony be
harmonious the book of acts uses the
language of be of one accord
and um you know there's this can
honestly be a little bit contentious
because um
there's kind of the question of well
like how like-minded because this is
there is a little bit of intellect here
a little bit of maybe some doctrine you
know in terms of be like-minded um in
other words kind of be on the same page
and that's i say contentious because
there's some question in the church
around like well like how on the same
page you know
like and um
it can get in certain church kind of
cultures and atmospheres it can get like
um like really on the same page like on
everything on the same page and it
becomes even sort of top-down forced you
will think like you know at least in our
context like you will agree with pastor
brett you know on everything and his
interpretation of everything you know
that gets very weird very quickly so um
i don't think that's quite what he's
getting at i i think um
honestly there's uh
well i will tell a little bit of story
there's a guy his name was um rupertus
meldinius what's his name very strange
name because he was uh in the 17th
century
so 1600s um and he lived through the 30
years war this was a um a war between
protestants and catholics in europe
and um it was a terrible it was bloody
and violent and it was both kind of
religious and it was political because
they were kind of striving for the
nation states this is why like for
example today like you know france is
like catholic
catholic you know well it's secular but
if if you're going to be religious in
france you're going to be christian
you're mean catholic you know that's
sort of and that was back in 30 years
war is kind of established um similarly
like germany is like protestant
it's a protestant country you know and
that's why you get this sort of these
countries that are like block like we're
catholic we're protestant we're this and
so there was like they were killing each
other over this because they were
struggling for what will this
nation be
which
camp you know so they're slaughtering
each other like like this is brothers
and i mean i was gonna say sisters
probably not a lot of sisters mostly
just the brothers
their outrageous testosterone isn't
killing each other
um
over that you know
my goodness um so rubertus he coined he
had this little phrase that he's writing
at this time trying he's trying to help
the church he's like my lord we've got
to do something so this is what he said
he said in essentials
unity
in non-essentials liberty
in all things charity
that's pretty good huh and and by
charity he means just love it's not he
doesn't necessarily mean like giving to
the poor but it's it's the the broader
sense of charity just love
and um i think this is really there's a
lot of wisdom here because what we
what's the easy thing to do is just to
keep adding to the essentials pot or the
pile so to speak you know just like well
that's essential and that's essential
and also this and also that and and you
know you just keep adding to like well
this is the things that christians agree
aka that that i believe and i want all
the christians to agree with me and so
you know i just keep adding to the
essentials file and this is kind of the
tendency in church history when actually
i think it's somewhat simple like um i
think peter probably would have had some
pretty basic things about christ in mind
you know like his birth his life some of
his teachings um
not some his teachings um
his death his resurrection his ascension
his return
sort of like the person of jesus like
jesus is the heart of the church and
this is who we center on
this is who we commit to
love and
um
and really um follow you know and so
there it's sort of like any i think
that's some of the essentials like
christ
the essential one
um
and then outside of that like in other
things you know like it's crazy when
i've heard of uh churches that will
literally split over silly things like
the color of the carpet
you know these are not essentials this
is a silly thing to
split over or you know i don't know
baptism or exactly how do you baptize
you know like i've heard of christians
like like you're not a real christian
because you you got water poured on top
of you instead of like going under the
water
you know and it's like well
i don't know is that is god like oh no
oh it almost counted almost you know i
don't
i'm not sure
uh but this is what we do right we add
all sorts of things to the essential
spot so i think just keep the main
things the main things you know and
essentials
um an essentials unity non-essentials
liberty all things charity let's keep
loving one another so um so that's first
like-minded he says
we should be like-minded um the second
sign of a true church is sympathetic we
should be sympathetic um to have
sympathy it means to have a shared
feeling
with i think in a way here peter's kind
of moving from the head to the heart so
the first one's a little bit about the
head like some doctrine some ideas some
stories about christ and such i think in
sympathize is um i think about a shared
love
um we naturally our minds kind of tend
to hear the word sympathy we think like
oh i've like feel for you you know bro
whatever um i wonder though if he might
mean some of that um although his other
words seem to get more into that you
know like we'll look at
love one another and be compassionate
and that seems very person to person
um this one i wonder if he's saying
basically have a um sympathize with it
with one another in the sense of have a
shared a common love so not just a
common idea or don't just be like-minded
but also um have a calm and a shared
love
for the lord jesus like feel with one
another um
towards god and have a have a common
love i think of uh i took my son dex to
a
cowboys game uh dallas cowboys this past
season
and um that was an inch i mean it was a
fascinating kind of experience this is
the adoration and worship in that place
is just outrageous um and we mean we
walk in and it's just like
a wall of sound just boom and people are
freaking out just the intensity you know
the people are painted various colors i
mean my son he walks in he's just like
he's never seen i mean a place this huge
you know this uh modern temple you know
just fascinating and uh and i'm thinking
you know we're kind of reflecting back
on that experience like what was it that
was a shared
love
you know it was a common love not just
for god so much there was for the dallas
cowboys
but that was that was they we were all
very much sympathizing with one another
for our shared love of you know the
cowboys in that moment um and i think in
a similar way we come here and it's a
shared adoration a shared love i mean we
just experienced it um as we sang and
worshiped the lord like
what is that that's us coming together
and expressing
together our love for christ um you know
sometimes people will
in various ways maybe have a hush
conversation with me after service or
take me out for coffee or something and
and they'll
to kind of process the idea of loving
god um and they'll say something you
know like i just um like i want to love
god but i don't really know
like if i do you know and they kind of
say it quietly because maybe i don't
know they might think i'm gonna get
angry at them or something i don't know
um
but actually this is it's funny how many
people have this conversation with so i
think everyone's sort of struggling
alone a little bit thinking i'm the only
one
you know when actually i've had this
conversation like i don't know a dozen
times or something and um you know when
they'll ask me like what should i do
like i don't know do i try to stir it up
you know do i just
grit my teeth and like i'm gonna love
god you know what i do
and my answer to them is pretty much
always the same i say um we'll just be
just be here
just be with us
and
you will you'll
catch it
like there's a phrase we use around here
that um christian discipleship is more
caught than taught
you know it's it's like you get with in
the same way if i wanted to make someone
a cowboys fan i just take into the game
you know i mean like it's one thing for
me to like intellectually like tell them
like oh you should love the cowboys
they're here's their history you know
and
championships a long time ago um you
know like that's like some intellectual
it's different when you go into the game
and it's like oh my gosh it's like it's
infectious that energy even if someone
didn't care about sports ball at all
and all of a sudden they might find
themselves a little caught up in the
right
it's caught this is who we are as human
beings we like catch things from others
and i think that's some of what peter's
getting at have this not only be
like-minded the head
but sympathize
feel with one another the heart you know
so that's the second sign of a true
church the
third sign
is loving
his exact phrase is love one another so
that's pretty clear this isn't so much
like loving god he's really clear like
love one another the um the greek word
here is philadelphoy which you might
kind of recognize like sounds familiar
um so the city of philadelphia is named
after this greek word so that of course
it means um well philadelphia is the
city of brotherly love you know so
philadelph to philadelphoy is literally
like um a brotherly ori the idea really
is a family like love and that's exactly
what peter writes like have a have a
philadelphia have a a family-like
connection in love for one another in
other words love each other like
brothers and
sisters um that's quite a bond i think
we kind of take that for granted you
know like oh yeah that's yeah that's the
church but it's like if that's really
true
wow i mean that's quite a call to the
people in this room we're called to
start learning to love them like family
that's i mean it's
it's interesting we um even in our
culture now we kind of are losing i
think the art of family
you know like we almost don't even love
our family like our family you know i
mean like even our
um even our nuclear family at times um
but even the extended much less extended
you know it's sort of like yeah those
people i never see you know
um
but there is something beautiful when we
can start to love people like family
there's
there's something to that um
i heard uh well there's a lady
named sally gary some of you recognize
her name she's a wonderful christian
writer um but it's really kind of both
through her writings and through a lot
of the folks who've actually found their
way to the table from a denomination
known as the um church of christ or
sometimes it's known as the churches of
christ
this for those unfamiliar you might know
the the
christian denomination that doesn't use
instruments in their worship that's kind
of
generally how people kind of know them
um
but uh you know the folks who have kind
of made their way from that tribe to the
table
there's you know all sorts of stories
baggage like any denomination it's not
perfect you know a lot of pain there um
yeah a lot of baggage but
there's also some really cool things
about that denomination and one is that
it is very tight-knit
um
now some of the downside kind of like
even in a family that's like super
tight-knit you can kind of get that kind
of back to the rubertus quote
and you know it can be a little bit of
like in all things you know or in
essentials unity in non-essentials unity
in all things unity you know that can be
the kind of downside to that tightness
um but the upside and i actually learned
this from sally kerry in one of her
books it was titled affirming a
wonderful kind of memoir um
and about her coming out as a gay woman
um
but she's talking about her own history
in the church of christ
and
um
i mean it's been a rich experience for
her and she says one of the things she
loved was when she was growing up um her
family was like the type of family that
when they went on vacation they went to
church
on sundays you know it's like if you're
vacationing over the weekend you find a
church and for her they were raised like
church of christ so it's like you don't
just find any church you know you find a
church of christ church and you get your
booty there you know and uh she said
what was so amazing though was she knew
like the moment she walked through those
doors
like she her family like they would
literally
um her mom dad brother sister like they
would be treated like family
and she just knew that in fact she said
there was some comfort for her even as
she traveled around like they would on
vacation go to different states and
whatever like there was some comfort in
the idea that like even if something
went terribly wrong on their trip like
you know got flat tire or car trouble or
just you know need a place to stay like
she said even at like a young girl like
eight or nine like she knew if we get in
trouble all we need to do is find a
church of christ church
and we'll be welcomed in like they will
take care of us
and i think that's that's that's that's
cool right that's pretty that's an
amazing kind of family-like love now i
think the trick is
how do you take that and start to
transcend
you know a denomination
or a tribe of like well these are the
people who are our people and they agree
with us in these ways and how do you
start to transcend that and treat um
everyone who walks through those doors
like family
like that's the trick in fact i heard um
because we've been i think taken steps
towards that i heard
uh this was maybe three or four weeks
ago
um the the tech team and the worst team
gets here unbelievably early y'all
probably don't know they're here like 2
2 30.
um
and so gary miner was here early
and getting stuff set up
and uh he was alone at that time and he
heard though that kind of like
of the little alarm system and uh so
it's just that someone came to the door
and so he kind of calls out because it
was early enough that others weren't
supposed to be there for you know
another 15 minutes he's like uh hello
and the voice that called back he like
didn't recognize
and he's like hey who who's there and so
he he ends up walking back it was a
gentleman
his name was michael and he was fresh
out of prison
and um
you know what do you do like when you're
in a place where you need help and you
don't have friends or family like in in
our culture even still people kind of
know like well
you go to a church you know
and so that's what he did he just
randomly was like he needed help this
was back during that cold snap we had
like three four weeks ago so it was
gonna be cold that night and so he just
needed help so it was gary miner it was
um
daryl adams
i think maybe marissa maybe perhaps
others i wasn't here that early
so i didn't i did not get to meet
michael but i heard that gary daryl
marissa
perhaps others got to like talk with
michael um
listen to him process his story they
prayed for him they bought him a hotel
room
for the night
they then i know daryl adams then drove
him to the hotel and then hurried back
because he was scheduled to be a greeter
uh that sunday so he was like hurrying
to get back in position
and uh and i just thought when i heard
that story i just thought man like
that's a beautiful expression
of of learning to be a true church right
and just to be clear we don't always get
this right
right like then we still got a long way
to go but i thought man that's a that's
a beautiful step for them to treat
anyone who walks through those doors
for whatever reason
you treat them like family there's
something beautiful about that
um so that's the third
the third sign of a true church um is is
to be loving the fourth sign is um he
says be compassionate
be
compassionate
um other translations say tenderhearted
and i like those translations tinder
something about that word is so bodily
like tenderhearted
you know it's like right in the core i
think i know kind of what it is to be
tenderhearted not so much because i'm
always tenderhearted it's more like i'm
extremely familiar with its opposite
anyone else familiar with that kind of
cold that kind of shutdown kind of
walled up you know um
at my worst that's kind of where i am in
fact i was reflecting like why do i why
am i so often cold-hearted
towards others and i thought of two kind
of moments a
um i get i tend to lose my
tenderheartedness um when i'm kind of
overly driven and overly ambitious i've
talked about this a number of times
where like in that moment people aren't
the way
like people are in
my way
uh i do this with my schedule i've gotta
stink and schedule i'm like a scheduler
you know so i've got the schedule and
the schedule says this is happening at
this time and i'm locked in
and it's just like oh my gosh you're
getting in my way you know it's like
this this might work even my kids like
my sweet children are like you're not on
the schedule you know um this is when
you know
uh oh
losing your tender heartedness so that's
the first the second is when i i um when
i allow my anger to kind of solidify
into resentment
you know anger can be good in the sense
it alerts us to an injustice
you know like hey something's wrong we
just got mistreated and that's not bad
to know that
um what happens is that anger it kind of
gets lodged in our hearts and minds
doesn't it so
and then we like allow it to just be
there
and it just
becomes a departed resentment and it
eats away at our tenderness
you know we're just not tender harder
we're not compassionate anymore in the
way that god calls us to be
so that's the fourth sign of a true
church the fifth and final sign
is to be humble
to be humble first peter 3 8 um
closes with this word humble it will
actually it reminds me of a passage from
matthew chapter 11 verse 29 this is
jesus he says take my yoke upon you and
learn from me for i am gentle and humble
in heart and you will find rest for your
souls i love the connection here between
the gentleness which i kind of take as
the point number four the compassionate
thing tenderhearted the gentleness of
christ the humility of christ in that
this somehow allows us to find rest
i think this is true even on a human
level when i interact with someone and
they are both gentle
like tenderhearted and they're humble
it's like it allows me to just go
i can just be myself in this moment
because they're not competing with me
you know what i mean like they're not
like trying to one up which just causes
something weird in me my probably just
my own insecurities that i'm like i'm
awesome too you know
we're both kind of doing this weird this
is where
the corporate world was so hard for me i
lord bless you all who are still in the
corporate world and i just it drove me
bananas i love them now my work in the
church because it's like this is now bad
you know like this wouldn't be good for
me to act in those ways or for other
people to not be you know i mean it's
just but in the corporate world it's
almost sort of like what everyone's
politicking you know i mean everyone's
trying to make like you kind of look bad
and i'm kind of awesome you know and
just i could just sense it underneath
the surface like in every conversation
everyone's kind of posturing and just oh
it was exhausting
and when someone though is gentle
and humble it's the complete opposite
it's like oh they're just being real
they're just themselves
but of course like we the church you
know isn't immune from this there's a
a guy he looks something his name is
rowan williams he looks like a cross
between dumbledore gandalf and santa
claus
here he is that's rowan williams
he is uh he's the former head of the
church of england a wonderful
writer if you like academic writing then
he's your guy
um wonderful theologian but he was
giving a talk because he was the head of
the church of england so it's like
church of millions of people and
um and he was a you know top dog and so
he was given a speech and he was known
for his like tremendous kindness and
tenderness i mean he's very
tender-hearted person but in this
talk he was like kind of
being a little bit a little pointed you
know i think he was talking to priests
and he said um
he said you know the church is in
trouble
when the clergy are overly concerned
with the color of their buttons
now he wasn't talking about fashion
in the anglican church the color of your
buttons
communicates your rank in the hierarchy
so for example like a lowly priest
pastor like me i would have black
buttons
um a bishop
kind of an overseer of pastors oh
red buttons
and then if you want to be like an
archbishop i think they have white it's
white or gray some other different
buttons
um now we can kind of listen to that and
be like well that's ridiculous these
priests and clergymen with their buttons
caring about their buttons i'm not so
foolish that i would care about buttons
well here's the thing
uh we all have our buttons don't we
don't we all have our you know i mean i
was thinking of like teen kind of
culture it's like shoes
shoes are the buttons of teenagers you
know um or you get a little older and
then it's kind of we just we all have
our ways you know of communicating our
awesomeness and our place in the
hierarchy you know whether it's the car
or the the house or the neighborhood or
even the social circles we all know
about name dropping and you know just
it's just these ways we all have our
buttons
but here's the thing we follow the jesus
the lord jesus who who gave up his
buttons who let go
of these outward symbols and trappings
of his awesomeness i mean that's exactly
what philippians chapter 2 is all about
he he was
who um was equal with god did not did
not count equality with god something to
be grasped but he emptied himself he
made himself nothing he became the
servant of all
gave up his buttons
and so what does that mean for us it
means
here in the church we're learning i'm
not saying we get it right all the time
right but we're on the path
we're learning to just be ourselves
just be ourselves
you know
not have to
show how awesome we are
how worthy of love because isn't that
kind of what's behind a lot of those
buttons
right i think it's not just like oh
people are so prided you know prideful
and arrogant and terrible like it's
really it's insecurity
you know it's like i want to be loved i
want to be worthy you know but this is
this is why we we worship god and this
is why we learn to love christ is that
we know that we know that we know that
we're loved
that we're loved and so we can just rest
in that
just rest in that i think man
what a beautiful thing for us as a
church community to be that matthew 11
to be that that gentle and humble
and then people could come here and just
find
rest is that who the table is called to
be like the place where people can just
rest
finally all of you be like-minded be
sympathetic love one another be
compassionate and
humble
let me pray for you
lord jesus
i um i just pray a
just a spirit of uh
of unity
of harmonious unity
over us
may we be united in our passionate
worship of you
may loving kindness make compassion
may humility
mark our every interaction
forgive us
for where we've fallen short
we do love our buttons
that help us to be secure enough in your
love
to know that we can let them go
do your good work in us
in the name of the father the son and
the holy spirit
amen
if you guys want to stand with us in
this last song
um as brett was telling me this week
what he was gonna speak on i thought
there is
not a song that i feel better embodies
the message that i hope our church is
putting out there to people as they walk
in these doors so
i just love these lyrics so you guys
take them in as we sing together
[Music]
come on proud
come all greedy
[Music]
come today
from near and far
come from the shadows
[Music]
come to the bank
to a table full of grace
[Music]
there's no winners
just come as you are
[Music]
come the eyes
come here
[Music]
oh
me
[Music]
we're ready to
feast
the parties
[Music]
is
ah thank you so much for that worship
team um it's kind of actually a good
reminder because we are actually having
a welcome to the table um class
uh at the end of the service was that
planned
anyway
so
if you are a visitor um we would love to
if you're this your first time we'd love
to kind of uh get to know you a little
bit there is a card um as you enter
around that hallway if you wouldn't mind
just kind of fill that out
just we just like to drop you a
little quick note say thank you for
being here and all that kind of stuff
also if
you feel like you called table at home
and you are wanting to support our
ministry you can do that by going to the
website and i'm going online there's
also a box as well that you can give
your donation
and
then since we're all standing
i am going to launch this off um
with this benediction
and if you'd like to receive this if you
wouldn't mind just holding at your hands
if you feel so glad
so you are a child of god
you
are a child of god
this is true on your best day
and it's true on your worst day
so as you go out with your week ahead
and it's yet to be determined highs and
lows and everything in between
go
filled with the insurance that you are
loved
you are worthy
and you are accepted
just as you are
and go
fill with god's holy spirit and the
desire to extend these same gifts and
grace and unconditional love to everyone
you come in contact with
thank you
again if you're saying for the table uh
welcome to the table class i'll be
you know we'll just meet over here
i'm looking forward to getting to know
you guys
[Music]
me
come now
[Music]
accepted
we're ready to
peace
[Music]
to keep them free
as a kingdom of praise